hello everyone and thanks for the
invitation to join you today and I'm
particularly honored to be here because
of the dedication of a dis event that we
heard before so I'm going to talk about
the sino-russian natural gas corporation
that has not been happening yet but I'm
going to try to convince why I think
this year will be the propitious one to
spur this cooperation and make and
strike a final deal so you just peep a
little bit so what I'm going to be doing
here i'm going to be reviewing a little
bit a historical setting I'm between
China and Russia or what has been going
on in the last decade I will compare the
sign of Russian oil and gas cooperation
highlight the distinctiveness of oil and
gas as commercial commodities and
potential foreign policy tools and then
i'm going to make four distinct
observations why i think on on on the
russian and on the Chinese side what
have been the domestic reach into
regional and global changes that make
this cooperation more likely in 2014 and
then I'll conclude with some I'll
conclude with some implications and
changes I foresee in the future so given
that um we know that we know that we the
China assign a Russian cooperation has
been very strong at the G jumping and
Putin meth fight no less than five times
in 2013 they are set to meet five times
in 2014 their trade is booming it's set
to reach 100 100 billion dollars in 2014
according to some estimates they have
been cooperating in global hotpot like
it Syria Iran the arms straight from
Russia have been growing to China and so
on and so forth on the flip side there
has been designed a Russian split which
is setting there as a historical
precedent where these two giants have
frozen their cooperation for something
like 30 years and on the negative side
their cooperation is there's like an
irritant in Central Asia where they find
themselves in competition and also this
Russian paranoia about the Chinese sort
of penetration of the sparsely populated
areas in eastern Siberia well despite
this kind of context which is the same
in oil and gas the puzzling thing to me
is the question is why has oil
cooperation been growing and and has
recently been even increased with a deal
to more than double oil the old
deliveries to China over the next 25
years while gas corporation has still
been stagnating I to answer this puzzle
I well I rely on data more than 25
interviews on each side and I kind of
like a mix of sources that I have
collected in the last two years when I
side this project um well I wouldn't
bother to explain this puzzle I want to
focus on I want to spend some few words
on how oil and gas are different as
commodities and our potential foreign
policy tools so given that and in here I
have a table which kind of summarizes a
little bit this given that oil is
fungible commodity internationally
traded with with very well known values
it the Sun cost of gas corporation and
of building pipelines is much higher in
gas than it is in all which means that
the overall gains of gas of oil
cooperation are higher than the overall
gains of all cooperation furthermore
given that in oil when we have a
shortage it or cope in or resources can
be much more readily replenished than in
gas cooperate
which make these two commodities very
different in terms of international
cooperation a second reason which is
actually I think the most important one
it's because we're it simply China
didn't need so desperately gas as it
needed oil in 2009 when this again that
oil gas oil deal was was was reached if
we look at the Chinese or energy mix oil
occupies like around nineteen percent
while gas today it occupies only four
percent of its consumption so um and
also China was very eager to diversify
away from sea lanes which were dominated
by the weather which still are dominated
by the US Navy and and if we consider
year 2009 when this deal was reached
Russia was was undergoing a deep
economic crisis and wasn't a historical
relationship with the West due to the
invasion of Georgia so if we take um so
now I'm just going to very quickly go
through into this for observation as I
mentioned before while I think that the
deal could be reached soon and I have
made for uplifting observation from the
Russian side and for from the Chinese
side so I don't have time here to defend
them all of them so I'm just gonna I'll
be happy to elaborate on this story in
the Q&A if somebody's interested in but
I'm just not really mentioned all of
them so as Jamila already said we had
this shell Harris revolution in the
United States which made the Russia the
European market over supplies because
some of these gas which was directly to
the US was routed to Europe and we had
this gas bubble in Europe and the
European oil and gas companies asking
for a negotiation of of gas prices to
gazprom on top of that gospel was gospel
is facing antitrust probe with european
commission that is charging it against
competitive anti-competitive measures in
eastern
europe so gasps girl has definitely
desperately been looking for new markets
and also new gas sources in eastern
Siberia on top of that given that top of
that we we are seeing a big a big
economic crisis in Europe in in Russia
which this time unprecedented Lee has
not it seems not being connected with
the prices of oil because in 2012 the
Russian Urals averaged 110 dollars per
barrel and nonetheless Russia has has
Russia growth has proven through an
insufficient russia russian oil prices
have proven insufficient to spur
economic growth even as russia's
reliance of these rents has continued to
rise so as what we see first time in
history is that even as prices of all go
up china russia is facing an economic
recession what that means is that what
could Russia do Russia would spur an
economic reform sort of like trying to
reduce its reliance of hydrocarbons but
that would be very costly economically
and politically so the easiest fix for
Putin in order to not impinge on the on
the fortunes of the super-rich on n on
its his own I think a political faith is
to find a new marketplace and I think
the dirac rational and the natural
answer is China once again and so
significantly this year 2013 when we
have seen this beginning of an economic
crisis and the end of the sort of energy
spurt growth there have been three
equity stakes deals which as I said
before are also unprecedented because
the oil deal was was was was decided
between even without try negating any
equity stake in the Russian
upstream which China has always been
very keen to obtain but in 2009 it
didn't get get any and with gas it seems
that is true stories go hand in hand so
Russia China is looking for an equity
stake and there have been some
presidents there are some store some
three examples that make this seeming as
a new possibility one is the amah LNG
deal where Russia where this novitec
which is one of the Russians independent
companies pledged to supply up to 3,000
tons of lng to China and Cho and cnpc
acquired twenty percent of equity stake
in this project second rosneft and its
its CEO Sachin as we heard before who is
by many considered the second most
important man in Russia right after
Putin he signed this memorandum of
understanding with GNPC to more than
double on the Russians deliveries of oil
to China and also to build a joint
venture in East Siberia which is still
just on a national level but it could
something could change here and third
petrochina has also declared it was to
invest in East Siberia and yeah it has
pledged to put like ten thousand billion
dollars in eastern Siberia as a means to
finalize this deal so there have been a
lot of changes from the Russian side and
also there has been this important
progress in the routine 2015 where
Russia has given up its opportunity to
be the swing supplier be playing being
able to divert its extra supplies from
Western Siberia to the east and being
and sort of play this arbitrage game
between Europe and in China so it has
been one of these most important
concessions from the Chinese on the
Russian side um so
sorry so this is the this is the
Russia's Eastern program which relies
mostly on the Kovac Tyler and Cheyenne
the fields which are two massive like
mammoths fields one has 1.3 trillion
cubic meters of gas and the other one
has to point but I think um and in order
to develop that Russia has relied on a
Eastern program which witch whose value
is between 80 to 90 billion dollars and
since Russia didn't want to put all its
eggs in the Chinese sort of basket it
tried to build multiple pipelines and in
order to avoid to rely on only one
consumer but ironically without the
Chinese participation all this effort
will be unjustified so it's a big
expense to avoid to be depend only on
China but then if China doesn't join it
doesn't really make sense on the Chinese
that although China can sort of play
wait and see as we already heard and it
can leverage its position as a consumer
there are reasons to believe the China
is also eager to finalize this deal um
just too well just consider this um
China in 2015 China is increased its
projected to increase its gasp
consumptions to 260 billion cubic meters
domestically it produces a hundred
billion cubic meters of gas so it could
theoretically may be increased to 200 +
150 which still leaves us with a hundred
and ten billion cubic metres of a gas
shortage which China could get from LNG
markets but then right now China is
competing with Japan that phased out its
nuclear and India that is also massively
increasing its consumption so um
everything else being equal it seems
that LNG competition between this
eastern market is going to Greece
massively so if China has to do with our
Russian gas that means the price of LNG
in these two markets is going to go up
and here I disagree a little bit which a
meal I don't
there's going to be a gas bubble there i
think if china doesn't get fresh and gas
i think the price of lng in this market
is going to go up and it and which is a
good news for consumers like Katara
Indonesia or Australia and so on but not
for China on the other hand also China
has been and this goes this fits into
the story of March West um China has
been eager to secure its end with
security of supply so to speak without
the intermediation of the US Navy
especially because of the sentence
situation in a South China Sea and East
China Sea and in this regard the march
west story fits well because that gives
it inland supply and I think Russia here
is a big player as well and then um so
this is just a slide showing how this
gas gas consumption is in China is
really a projected to take off due to
environmental consideration in China and
this new leadership that is really seems
willing to tackle this environmental
problem um so this is um just showing
how the new route the eastern route is
avoiding the wigger region and seems
young that China finds really sensitive
and it's also reaching the main Chinese
markets which are more on the eastern
side um well regard Erica I'm kind of
doubtful that the shine shale in China
is going to really take off in the next
ten years because of a lot of problems
which are summarized here geology
geography the water also the shale
deposits are much deeper in the ground
than in the United States but I think
most of all the biggest constraints are
institutional in nature oops
um well just just this eighty percent of
the acreage where shale gas in China
lace is owned by CNPC and sinopec which
are these two big behemoth that really
don't have a incentive to develop these
resources if a price a reform on the
pricing in China is even if it's a
preform on pricing is not rich they
don't have an incentive to develop those
resources because grass is so cheap in
China that it really doesn't make sense
for them to kind of and they have other
half please do have conventional gas to
play with so and also there is even an
institutional kind of debate between the
NDRC and the ministry of land we land
them something I remember the whole name
resources in China whose responsibility
it should be this shale gas they didn't
even figure out that yet so it's going
to take some time for China to solve
these institutional problems so these
are some just joint ventures between
Western and Chinese and OCS but they
just have minority shares for now in
China um so to sum up I have made a four
distinct observation of each side about
why the deep hesitancy in action and
ambivalence could be soon transform
between these two giants and I turn to a
country specific analysis on both sides
and just to sum up I think in Russia the
rise rise of some actors like Igor
Sechin who are pressing and other
independents like novitec who are
pressing for the end of this law of the
pipeline's we're only Gazprom has the
right to export pipeline gas in Russia
it's significant and also the Kremlin's
frustration of these unsuccessful gasp
negotiation techniques on the China side
I I said that the shale gas revolution
will not be so significant to kind of
change the import equation and on the
other hand we have arrived in the
particular kind of leadership that is
more sensitive to climate
climate concerns and just to finish I
don't think the competition in Central
Asia will be a big irritant in it will
disrupt this geopolitical logic of
deepening the sign of Russian gas the
gas ties if anything I think given that
China has contracted a 60 BCM pipeline
from Turkmenistan and at Central Asia is
increasingly important actor in the
Chinese portfolio I think that should
act as a s kind of like um stimulus for
Russia to move and to finalize in the
sooner and I don't think and for Japan a
roughly similar pattern i think prevails
is Japan's then somewhat on the sides of
this pipeline negotiations yeah this
China Russia pipeline politics although
in the oil deal Russia had played the
Japanese gardener a rush is more eager
to finalize the more desperate to
finalize this deal so I don't think
Russia has any incentive to play the
Japanese card um I think Ukraine is
somewhat of a wild card in this
relationship although the natural
explanation would be that Russia is
going to turn even more eastwards
towards China obviously but even even
without Ukraine given the reasons I
already kind of advanced here I think
that will happen and I think it's also
interesting to consider the alternative
scenario if that doesn't happen so if
kind of like Russia doesn't take the
after 2020 window because China now is
supplied until 2020 so the question is
how much of a window does Russia have so
if Russia doesn't really take advantage
of soon of a window after 2020 I think
we're going to see a very long straddle
squaw where China is going to feel its
gap with energy and with a burning
additional call because LNG is going to
get very expensive so I don't think it's
going to be able to rely only on energy
I'm finishing a and so what are the
policy implications of the oldest I
think an important one is
on climate change so if China and Russia
rich deal actually it would be a good
news for climate change we can use of
because of containing the energy prices
in Asia and um another last thing I
think I'm skeptical about this
unsettling implications of a sign of
Russian energy centers and dent in
Eurasia I think they're a consortium I
mean beyond energy is kind of weak I if
it's not set on specific issues like
Syria and Iran so I think yes there are
big big prospects for this comparison
but there's only mainly set on economic
profit more than this parallel I'll be
less pronounced willingness to
counterbalance American power thank you
before we open it up to questions let me
make a few observation first and I think
as I said before this panel did a lot of
devil in detail I will say they
delivered a lot of detail and with the
risk of being oversimplifying let me
make a comment or two gasps promise
Russia Russia is Russia Inc China's cnpc
and some others is China inc kazakhstan
kazakh inc what we have here in to a
degree but obviously I'm oversimplifying
we have state capitalism at work so
state capitalism at work by obligation
should be looking at what's good for the
nation as a whole obviously that has
implications that are totally obvious
but we do have state capitalism we have
focused on Russia we focused on China we
focused on individual countries and
we've said in passing companies have
minor shares in China independent
producers are they always in cordons
with state capitalism that's the
so-called national interest another
theme that has been mentioned this more
in both panels this morning is
disability and security
but how do we get anything out we need
stability we need security that is a
contrast to see us off unless we unless
China follows and communicates that
poverty is insecurity but it's not
always implemented how do you alleviate
it so with those sorts of things I'd
like to just leave one last column
anything but state capitalism is also
business just at a different level than
we're accustomed to in the United States
so questions if you're in a center and
if you can introduce yourself and your
affiliation now Jenny can I just before
we start with question can I just
clarify it was the last speaker didn't
agree with me but LNG I just wanted to
clarify that I think perhaps my point
was not was not really properly
understood that I was talking about oh
and Ziggler was a question mark and I
think that the issue they is yeah you
have free trade agreement with the
United States mature LNG markets south
south korea japan very attractive that
the most attractive markets for for lng
but i think what's important to remember
is that these markets there is a lot of
uncertainties by these markets in in
terms of the economic performance number
one number two in terms of their energy
efficiency policies and the numbers
rebar their policies in relations to
energy mix I'm talking about nuclear and
coal use so in the in a sort of
worst-case scenario if the demand is not
as high as expected general benefit from
the LNG glut that will appear as a
result Thank a child from CSIS I like to
take off on marinas last point on the
window of opportunity from Russia and as
shamil and mr. ma the question on
whether the Chinese and Russians will
come to a final pricing agreement when
mr. Putin visits china in may or not and
if so with the pricing terms be more
favorable
the Chinese then then the Russian side
on their previous negotiating position
given what's already happened over all
that you all described and if it's not
agreed in May will there ever be an
agreement between China and Russia I
have to believe the upstream economics
at both China and kavika isn't so rich
as to be able to support a very
expensive pipeline project without very
note lonette backs to the field and
maybe they will never be an agreement
given the difficult economic side like
your comments from both of you on that
maybe we can normally I would say two
questions but I think since this is a
complex question we should address it
first Marina I think my my personal
opinion is if they don't reach an
agreement in May at least if they don't
agree on something in May and then they
don't finalize the agreement by the end
of this year I see difficult the
possibility I agree with you that
there's not going to be an agreement for
either a long time or never again
because I don't think cnpc will be
generous with gas / many more right now
well this is just anecdotal knowledge I
have or I heard that CNPC has offered up
to 50 billion without any interest to
gas boom which is a huge amount of money
even without even for country like China
and obviously this is going to come only
in exchange for equity stakes and some
big reduction in price but there but I'm
worried because they're observers like
Sergei come leaven in russia in russia
saying that the russia is still not
willing to subsidize the the chinese
market and i think right now Russia
doesn't have any other alternative then
as it likes to say to subsidize the
Chinese market
yeah I want to add a few points to that
yes obviously there are issues that I've
outlined that put pressure on on gas
prone to reach an agreement with the
Chinese in terms of economics 11 issue
is the pressure that the pressure that's
coming from Rosneft them from Igor
Sechin to get access to power of savory
pipeline to supply 16 BCM of gas from
Rosneft old gas fields in this Siberia
it's an important factor but there is
one thing to take into account that
Rosneft does not want to spend a penny
towards the development of power of
Siberia pipeline unless they get some
kind of equity in that pipeline then
I'll as you know they've been looking
for equity in Transneft for Russian
pipeline monopoly so that what kind of
equity approach in the pipeline could
perhaps some would change the attitudes
of Russian place and I think that
another issue is is the issue of I've
aradia outlined oversupply awful NGO
under supply of LNG in Asian markets
because that's an important factor but
the most important factor that's already
been put on the table but the Chinese
side apart from the loan that they
offered is the the joint potential joint
venture was I'm not sure whether it will
be Gazprom it could be some other place
in Russia joint transportation and join
marketing of Russian gas in Asian
markets and this is this is a very big
development very very interesting
proposal from the Chinese side which
which changes a lot of the dynamics of
these negotiations okay i think the
maybe the most important time of the
russia and china coverage under
corporation is the last year 2013 and as
we have so that not only the chinese
about
the Russian government so they how many
they have made many declarations about
two countries and incorporation about
the superior of a Saborio energy the
Civil real gas filed and the gas
pipeline and I i think this year maybe
the this year's a process maybe as the
continued of the last year's agreement
thanks up Alex Cooley Harmon Institute
here and I'd ask the big question I
wanted to so I can ask to follow up
questions one is and the moderator might
want to answer this too we've talked a
lot about Kazakhstan and Raph mentioned
turkmenistan as part of his remarks but
we haven't really talked about
Turkmenistan were arguably the you know
Chinese relationship has been the most
dramatic in terms of sort of supplanting
and substituting for gas problems so if
anyone wants to pick up you know shamil
or Emma or our distinguished moderator
to talk about maybe lessons learned from
this new Turkmen Chinese relationship
i'd be interested in that and then Ned I
think we would all be really interested
if you could give us a two minute primer
because as we see you've done a lot of
interesting work on Chinese corporate
social responsibility and you talked
about sort of the fusion between public
goods provision and sort of CSR but
could you expand a little bit is there
and maybe all your work also on Chinese
mining is there a kind of chinese style
of csr how is it similar different than
what we're used to here in the west
thank you perchance using the floor let
csaw start and then we can all address
the other issue for you so you guys get
time to craft a great response yes
credit back when God you CRO me so I
think with uh with Chinese CSR I mean
it's a very understudied topic it
doesn't help that it's there's nothing
transparent organizations that we're
talking about we're looking at China CSR
but really I draw it back to a lot of
heat that the Chinese received in africa
around 2009-2010 when it was really the
spotlight was starting to be put on that
what they were doing in Africa
particularly in Sudan actually and and
and kind of the negative atmospherics
they were having in the area which
really I think caused them to kind of
think strongly about csr not only as as
you know what are we doing locally but
also what are we projecting publicly as
an image so on both of those respects as
a couple of things so so one on the on
the local level I mean I think the CSR
goal for the majority of Chinese
operations wherever they are has always
been to minimize the need to involve the
capital in any in a particular problem
all right so like to keep it very local
and now they don't have the same
corporate governance restrictions that a
lot of multinationals have Western
multinationals listed multinationals so
that allows them to operate in a much
easier way and that in that sphere the
big challenge in the local level for a
while or the status quo opinion was that
you know regardless of what they're
doing whether it's kind of your standard
CSR stuff which I think you see more of
you know the post 2010 which is this
kind of hospital school type of thing
that the Western multinationals do and
then putting aside for a moment which is
kind of the natural benefits of whatever
they happen to be doing which gas is a
particular case is the local employees
right so I mean the kind of the status
quo opinion for a while was that the
Chinese are you know kind of bring in
their own labor and the sort of thing
and and and so they're not recruiting a
lot of local jobs no offside mentioned
that you know an ecto be there it's you
know the locals were kind of complaining
about how they don't get the good jobs
and that sort of thing so honestly I
think there's a couple of interesting
points there which is which is one that
it's not so so from a public relations
perspective they've clearly chanting to
realize that's a huge sticking point
because now whenever you hear them
talking about csr
or something related to csr and in a
public sphere they always focus on how
many locals that they're hiring i mean
they know that that is a criticism that
they received in the past okay i think
you know getting below the surface on
that their problems with local workers
are the same problems that western
multinationals have at the end of the
day which is that while I'm sure there
are a lot of people in October that
would love to be petroleum engineers
they don't have the training to do that
you know and that's always been the case
right i mean so it's a you know it's not
just cosmic dance around the world where
a lot of contracts require some sort of
local capacity to be involved and it
Cadogan is a particularly tricky case
because they also like to put in you
know levels of management levels of a
responsibility that have to do it and i
think in that case there's no reason to
mystify the chinese experience versus
the Western multinational experience and
one that they should struggle at the
same issue okay that's one thing i do
think that the Chinese again maybe this
is part of the local profile like the
keep is that they actually in many ways
i'm going to talk outside of my name
because i said just a different bag and
i don't really have time for it but but
with it comes to energy i mean again the
gas thing is a serious thing right so
like this this whole situation with the
gas in southern kazakhstan is in theory
a great development for southern
kazakhstan okay but you don't see the
same sort of you know high-profile kick
off of there that you would have if a
western multinational was going to
gasify all these towns itself get
something kazakhstan all right i mean
there was a there was a signing ceremony
was going to Beijing it wasn't in South
Kazakhstan there's a couple of comments
this is great for it for Kazakhstan but
not nearly the same look and I think
this goes back to what other people are
saying wrath had mentioned other people
to mention it which is that the Chinese
know that you know there that there is
this kind of seen a phobia they keep a
low profile in that respect so I guess
that for a two-minute primer that be my
22 in a primer I mean again just to say
quickly i think post 2010 things changed
significantly for them but there's
there's no reason to mystify a lot of
there
their problems the big difference is
that they don't have the same corporate
governance requirements that a Western
multinational does which allows them to
operate locally a lot easier than been
on West multinationals thanks let me
just interject with an anecdote from
shale in Nigeria shell for many years
was just sending in its own engineers
and hiring local people in fact they
hired some very talented local people to
do the low level jobs even high school
graduates then all of a sudden they
became a Nigeria zation policy in
Nigeria which meant they had to
Nigeria's if you want upper management
including engineers and they brought in
Nigerian engineers from England for
example people who have been educated
the local said something they're not us
so in other words there was a nine
minority problem they were not
considered and I'd be afferents if you
want EBO people so the question that
I've always found very puzzling is you
want to employ local people one thing is
the low level but your stare 30 40 years
why you do you not have a plan of how do
you bring even people up to speed so you
have engineers of the future that is
part of CSR although as rightly pointed
out it's too often looked at building at
hospital building that school and moving
on so in response to the other questions
why do we start at one end of the table
and anyone can interject in our land at
the end or energy i think in jamia you
were asked question in terms of
turkmenistan i think that in terms of
lessons they end up the problem in the
relationship between russian took many
stunnas you know always been the fact
that of maine stands been a backup gas
producer for russian gas to Europe and
for Russian domestic consumption has
been a traditional way the gas system
was organized and as long as us as soon
as there was a depression of gas demand
in Europe gasps from stop stop buying
gas from Turkmenistan obviously the way
it was done was quite damaging I think
though would you know
in terms of relationship between Moscow
and the mains done as you know you know
they stop they just closed the taps and
stop taking taking gas even though they
had an agreement was took me instant to
take certain volumes of gas which result
an explosion of a pipeline there the
challenge what remains done in not
respect obviously was they needed to
find this a market and here you know
China really came up with an offer
turkmenistan could not refuse no loans
companies coming in building all
infrastructure taking that gas so she
took meds were happy to provide equity
and if your budget ninety percent of
your budget when it went up from seventy
percent dependence on gas up to ninety
percent dependent on gas exports if your
budget is dependent you know you have to
go with with a company or was it was it
was a was a play that is ready to take
your gas and Chinese obviously know that
that made some was in a very difficult
situation I think what they offered was
was you know very good deal for both
parties and the question is took many
some obviously wants to diversify their
gas exports and but the European the
Iranian issue is the supplies to run are
quite limited it's it's not really a
growing market even though they study
supplying more gastro to run and
European market is depressed market the
only market potential market is is India
and in terms of lessons I think
turtleman's won't learned one lesson is
that they cannot they cannot be
dependent on one particular player
that's the first lesson they learn the
second lesson the loan is other
countries play their own games
particularly by John despite all the
talk about as Eric providing
infrastructure for exports of gas then
it's not really there and a serious i'm
not really interested in supplying
central gas central asian gas to europe
at
stage because I interested more in
playing games geopolitical games
political games was a player with their
neighbors and also to at the end of the
day it's a commercial interest in all
that much in supplying their own
gas to Europe instead of instead of
central asian gas so all this other talk
about you know providing providing
infrastructure be no developing you know
expert infrastructure for central asia
gasps it's always been a part of part of
we know normal foreign policy you know
strategy of azerbaijan let me it's a
complex question in one respect but let
me give again which i've noticed for an
anecdote as i mentioned before one of
the challenges is Russia and China rank
or Kazakh ink or even in this case
Turkmen ink that's obviously an
exaggeration but it shows that there's
state capitalism or business at a
national level but one of the challenges
that I've seen in Turkmenistan and that
goes along with basically your question
is how did it approach they're trying to
approach business and one anecdote the
one that struck me very much is when a
Turkmen representative said about India
why can't they be more like Russia and
China in other words we talked to them
get a decision but there's complexity
then to have the added complexity that
there might be an international or
corporation involved so the challenge
that I find is state capitalism
challenges capability sometimes on how
do they have the capability even to act
like businessman when the national
business costs private businesses and I
think that's one of the challenges in
Central Asia they are asking them to
take on responsibilities which all new
for them and that takes time even for
the most sophisticated people it's
obviously much more detailed than that
but only one more question because some
of us would like to eat 12 okay two
questions you have your lobbyist on your
behalf and devil
lunch okay thank you very much for a
fellow panties you from rusi I be very
quick as you can see on the CSR point an
interesting element which I had been
hearing my discussions in Beijing
talking to people of Montcalm is that
they talk about complex sensitive
investment and I think they're really
focused on this idea and it's you know
conflict sensitive was that mean it
doesn't mean actually alleviating
conflict in terms of wars and whatnot
it's really about making sure that they
can do business and not you know be
troubled and so there's a big push I
think from off come to try to address
this at a very specific question went to
gesture dr. Marr which was in China
we've seen this big anti-corruption
Drive which mostly seems driven against
a specific individual joy on Khan and
his various people sort of who worked
for him a lot of whom were a part of the
cmp see and petrochemical industry
within China I'm wondering if there's a
possibility that this could have some
sort of impact on CM pcs external push
in Central Asia in particular and when
if any thoughts on that and then maybe
for the panel more broadly have we seen
have it has anyone observed a noticeable
shift or change in china's energy policy
towards Central Asia since she Jinping
is coming to power thank you okay then
why'd you ask them my name is Victor
Braun Chuck energy advisor Princeton
canceled on world affairs to Princeton
New Jersey actually obviously the motor
energy policy has shifted very much but
triangle relationship between Central
Asia China and Russia in you have not
been changed very much you needs Russian
energy Russia needs money China needs
energy and money so but recently cronies
of mr. Putin I mean in mr. timchenko his
key player in Paul trade and other have
been imposed sanctioned by the US
government and so we we have seen huge
turmoil it now in a Russian stock market
and particularly in a lot of Russian oil
state-owned monopolists have fallen as
well so what do you think
a serious impact in can particularly
financial planning in terms long-term
investing in this triangular Asha
Central Asia in China thank you I think
we start with you CSO it's going to be
very popular yeah music to my ears I
have to admit yeah yeah we'll have to
talk offline about that more because
it's interesting concept for sir I mean
I think it gets back to what I was
trying to trying to what I'm trying to
explore with the difference between
something like a railway and a gas
pipeline right I mean you know putting
aside the security issues you know which
are substantial I mean the have
completely different implications one
another if you're going to connect two
countries you know by rail or by our by
guess I think I don't sit I honestly I
don't have I mean I should have a beer
later and talk about it okay yeah yeah
leave it at that sorry does anyone else
wish to interject there
can you speak up please yes I think
Turkmen gas to Europe is not even an
issue because of the unresolved status
legal status of the Caspian Sea so it's
not going to happen anytime soon on the
other hand as traumeel said Russia has
used Turkmen gas to make up for its own
production and to sell it to Europe on
higher prices so China was a welcome
presence when it came to talk medicine
but I think right now the Kirkman's are
a little bit stuck with the Chinese as
well which makes that which makes this
mounting xenophobia to rise even more
and I think if Russia was a sensible
actor it could use this new situation to
sort of restore a little bit its
influence in the region but I don't see
that happening I think that is a
provocative term sensible actor shamil
which I big dick to ask a question but I
didn't quite maybe misunderstood you're
talking about triangle relationship
between Russia Chanin's and Central Asia
is that that was your question was
focusing what is the potential for that
relationship I think that I think there
is having two to two ways of that things
could work out as always they could be
the third line the first way obviously
all these structures say CEO and the in
a relationship taxon tuck customs union
involving involving Kazakhstan obviously
could play certain role by the end of
the day Central Asian countries and in
Russia I service economies to China I
think we should admit it some people
call it resource colonies or whatever
but I would prefer more diplomatic term
no service economies so and the question
is a lot will depend on China's
attitudes I would I don't think it's so
much to do with with with Russia and
central asia i think at the end of the
day I think Chen will be in the driving
seat and whether China will want to have
this triangular ship or not that will be
up to the no different sort of views
within the State Council how about
China's role in international affairs in
and in asia-pacific in the Middle East
in Europe so a lot of things will be
driving that relationship but at the end
of the date will be China the driving
that relationship I think at this point
sorry can I just actually know that I've
had a chance to have a little bit of
think I haven't something to say no an
interesting example of what may be
considered conflict sensitive investment
would be the money that that the Chinese
gave to summer cousin during the crises
okay so what I'm specifically thinking
of is when the during the financial
crises the commodity sector took a huge
hit in around the world including in
Kazakhstan and ArcelorMittal kazakhmys
the NRC at glencore might have been
there they all basically huddled
together and said listen we can't keep
all these people on staff all these
people that were employed and mining
that's a big deal because in Kazakhstan
is not a huge population and it's very
you know employee intensive industry so
when you know ArcelorMittal which
employs like 55,000 people in Kazakhstan
you know is thinking about shedding
quite a bit of a workforce it's a big
deal and what the guys in sambrook
basically said was ok instead of firing
everyone why don't you just use this
time of downturn as an opportunity to
improve your infrastructure and you know
get the machinery up and running and
these kind of capital cost type things
right and we'll give you you know all
the money you need to do that and all
the money they gave them to do that came
from China you know so I think you know
again if you're looking at long-term
relationships right China wants a stable
kazakhstan Kazakhstan wants a stable
China because that's a good customer and
those kinds of the way that they can use
their money in those particular you know
you know situations is perhaps a great
example of a very conflict sensitive and
investment in the sense that everything
is about maintaining stability and I
think you would say the same thing about
the gas pipeline that they gave the
seven hundred million dollars for I
would just like to interject one thing
before on da one it's not just about
stability if you looked at this and
Germany is not in the economic power
visa V the energy game but the German
approach to work is very very simple if
you got a downturn you still keep your
employees busy you somehow do not fire
them because you have a long-term
investment and if you fire them you may
not be able to rehire them so the
question is keeping people engaged it's
a different perspective and I think
that's one of the things that one has to
look at and should look at even in the
energy it's not short-term its long-term
and the question is how do you affect
something long term and employment is
one of the long term if you fire your
engineers you may need and tomorrow
where are you going to find them
interesting enough just on an anecdote
in Germany when the pharmaceutical
businesses actually went somewhat out of
business people found new jobs it is
almost impossible for Germany although
was a pharmaceutical power in 1995 it
lost it because people took different
jobs had you maintained that they could
have come back there was a downturn
there was competition so there's
something to be thought about it's not
just CSR it's also a long-term
perspective maybe that's a hidden value
of quote state capitalism now I'd like
to end at this point for lunch because
otherwise we will be deemed impolite
that means the Harriman Institute we
can't have that if all of the speakers
we join Alex and myself to go to the
faculty house and everybody else if we
can resume here at 2 15 so we can have
the last panel immediately we will have
a full stomach so hopefully we'll still
have the energy to talk about it then so
to 15 it's going to be a little bit of a
compressed lunch but
hopefully we can be back in time the
reason is we need to stop at four
o'clock today